chapter nine surf lucky waves what do
you mean by
that
so if we've listened to any of uh how I
built this guy Ra's uh podcast um I love
at the end he asked the same question
how much of what happened in your
outcome because he's interviewing you
know these fascinating guests who've had
these companies they've built and in
most cases had some sort of an
extraordinary outcome and you always ask
the question how much of your success is
because you're good you worked hard or
you got lucky and it's always
fascinating to listen to people's
response
and the truth is if if we think about it
um luck has an incredible amount to do
with the outcome and luck can be
distilled down into one word which is
timing the right idea at the right time
executed on and so I talk about that you
know surfing is is such an amazing sport
I'm I'm currently my place in Florida uh
we get some waves here so I attempt to
get out there and surf although you know
being a landlock Canadian uh you know we
don't get to do that very often but it's
it's it's what's so cool about the sport
is that literally it is all about
identifying the swell swimming out to be
in the right spot paddling in at the
right moment and then standing up and
riding the wave at exactly the right
time and if you get any of that wrong
it's a miss you either get Rick rolled
into the whitewash or you miss the wave
and it it goes past you and so I use
that to think about you know business
and how businesses really align with
that sort of thinking and in general I
say you know any any startup there's
kind of four critical elements that's
required to take something that's a
startup and become become something
that's scalable and ultimately
sustainable and that is you need a
Founder with a um an idea and ideas are
like noses everyone's got them but
that's kind of Baseline you need that
second you need a different strategy not
a better strategy anytime you say it's
better than you're comparing yourself to
a market leader so you're already
talking about a minimal part of the
market leftover so I talk about how do
you create a different third is you need
a team a team of people who are actually
going to help um carry the mission and
be the missionaries that take it to the
finish line and finally you need
execution and this is actually even more
important than the team and the example
I use is that when Team Canada sent all
these Superstar NHL players to the
Nagano Olympics back in 98 was the first
time nhlers ever went we had Messier we
had Gretzky we had like the who's who of
hockey going and we were going to for
sure win the championship we didn't even
get a RS and the reason why is even
though we had all these great players
they couldn't execute they couldn't work
as a team so execution trumps the the
potential abilities of the team so those
are the four elements that are required
but above all of that you need luck
meaning the right idea at the right time
and you know what the right idea at the
wrong time is still the wrong idea and
then I talk about that you know not all
waves are equal in life right like a
Northshore wave is different than a wave
in Southern California versus a wave in
Florida so the type of raves we ride
will determine the type of outcomes that
we can expect in business and uh yeah
it's again I think the whole the whole
point though get in the water and start
paddling you can't can't be watching it
from the the shoreline yeah there's
always people that love sitting in the
uh the stadium watching uh life but uh
chapter 10 says leave a Lego Legacy Lego
is a big name today it kind of was a big
name when I was a kid then went away and
came back what do you mean by that yeah
you know Lego is the ultimate toy um
these guys have uh first of all it's a
Danish uh company and my ancestry is
Danish as well so there's some affection
to that and they they are now the
largest toy company in the world um even
though they're private so it's not known
but they have incredible like a top 10
Global brand and the story is actually
fascinating too because they came from
humble beginnings they were originally a
wood um a wood toy company that evolved
into these plastic blocks they almost
went bankrupt in the early 2000s which
is shocking um and it's just it's
amazing to see where they are today so
look I think when we start off in our
career um it's hard to know how we're
going to be able to build anything of
significance and I kind of think of that
the same way with Lego blocks Lego
blocks are just kind of a pile of blocks
lots of potential but just blocks and on
their own they're not that significant
but as you snap them together there's
things that we learn uh along the way
based on how we build it that ultimately
create a structure that is beautiful and
meaning ful and if you've created Lego
structures which it sounds like you have
you also recognize that once you've
created a structure that that's pretty
cool that stands independent that's
pretty cool on its own but ultimately
when you create a landscape with a bunch
of structures that is awesome so it's
the idea of going from dependence to
Independence to interdependence and
building a life that actually is
creating more impact around other people
and so you know yeah the chapter just
uses the the idea behind blocks and how
do we create more meaning in terms of
Our Lives of going from just being
successful to significant and growing
our circle of influence and quite
frankly like what you're doing like you
releasing your your book your podcast
and uh YouTube channel you've created
all of this is growing your circle of
influence to be able to build value in
other people's lives and is a part of
the legacy of what you've
created you got a Bonus section here
that says red wagons are not meant to
rust I've seen a lot of Rusty red wagons
what do you mean by that well this is
true I have seen a lot of Rusty red
wagons I mean Ben Franklin said that
most people die at age 25 they just
waited 70 to be
buried and it's also said that the
wealthiest place in the world is the
graveyard where most people go with
their best ideas and best intentions
still within them you know books that
were never written songs Never sung
businesses that were never started that
humans are the only species that are
capable being less than what's possible
so you think about it a tree will grow
as high and as big as it can you know
squirrels will gather as many nuts as
possible for winter as they can ants
will you know collect as much food for
winter as they can to support the colony
but it's only the us as humans that have
this choice to be able to be average or
less than what's possible and so the
idea that at the end of my life I want
to know that I have found all of my
internal potential and left it all
behind on the field of life um one of my
mentors Jim ran used to say in life you
may not be able to do all you find out
but make sure you find out all you can
do and um you know my dad I referen in
this
book so kind of crazy that at the front
end of this book my my father passed
away from coid and you know I know Co
had an incredible impact on the world in
general but when it happens that close
to home it's like wow this this was real
and at the end of the book my mother
passes away kind of as a a byproduct
also of Co and so what I would say is it
it it it was a softening process in
terms of my ability to kind of lean in
and understand um but you know the value
of my parents my life but I I reference
that to say that my father I recognize
now the incredible value and principles
that he instill my life and you know he
said something when I was young and it
made such impact that I actually wrote
it out and put it on a bed frame next to
my bed but he said to me he said Brad
life you're going to pay one of two
prices the price of discipline or the
price of regret the price of discipline
is going to weigh ounces it's going to
cost you something but the price of
regret weighs tons and will crush you
under its weight and those words they
still haunt me but they certainly haunt
me at a young age and in the mornings
when I'd wake up and it'd be dark and
cold as it gets in Canada you know I
would read those words and to make the
difference be whether I'd roll over or
I'd roll out and embrace the discomfort
and take on the the possibilities of the
day and so this chapter is really about
it how do we do that I actually tell a
story of running the ultramarathon in
Hong Kong which is 100 kilometer race um
I'm not a distance Runner I'm not
supposed to be I was a sprinter as a kid
you know I'm kind of built like you
Richard and um it's uh yeah it makes it
harder for guys like us to go in wrong
long distances unless you're David
Goggins I guess but um but it just it's
like I was it all came down to the the
Curiosity of was it possible did I have
it within me to do this race which
actually was Legacy race from the giras
who are the original badasses from World
War II I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clip's from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out